Miley Cyrus and Liam Hemsworth returned  to the place where they first met  [Music]  fishing on the beach every day was  pretty fun Miley and Liam first met on  Tybee Island while filming the last song  in 2009 and eight years later they were  turned looking happier than ever  the couple was spotted having some jet  skiing fun on the island located near  Savannah Georgia on Saturday long as man  you feel like you do wrong  the younger now singer flashed her big  smile and even bigger engagement ring  next to her handsome beau unlike the  lucky 7 Miley visited her fiance for the  afternoon of adventure a nice break for  Liam who is currently filming his new  movie killerman in Georgia I really  don't think there's anyone hotter that's  like making films as him  [Music]  you